today is the Iowa caucus and tomorrow is
Groundhog Day that's the day the
groundhog peeks out of his hole sees
Trump has won Iowa and boroughs to
Canada that Gophers a loser
yeah I'm Topher today is also the first
day of Black History Month think about
it what better way to celebrate Black
History Month than with a caucus in Iowa
I think they have to black people there
all right what else is going on Bernie
yeah this is a big day with the caucus
and we don't have the info yet no not
yet yeah but it's gonna come in soon
analysts say that for Bernie Sanders to
win
he needs college students to show up at
the polls yeah
which explains slender Sanders new
campaign slogan I've got pizza and I'll
do your laundry Bernie Sanders said if
he beats Hillary Clinton in Iowa it will
be quote one of the biggest political
upsets in the modern history of our
country
yeah it's true nothing like it has
happened since the last time Hillary
Clinton ran in Iowa what he's talking
about the audience was just like that's
true
President Obama is planning to visit a
u.s. mosque for his first time as
president yeah
when asked why Obama said I wanted to go
to the one place in America where I
won't see Donald Trump I just
new Barbies coming out new Barbies will
come in different sizes and with more
realistic body types not only that the
new Ken dolls come with beer goggles so
just how are we doing we all good we're
all show is free you pay nothing Taco
Bell in the news Taco Bell has a new
Super Bowl deal where people can order a
mystery food item today the CEO of RB
said hey we've been given out mystery
food
[Music]
you